if you're so ambitious show me here's my  real question if you really want it and  by the way you get to choose your  work-life balance you know that's on you  like that's not me to choose or anybody  else what I'm passionate about Steven to  be very frank with you is what didn't  you do from Friday 5:00 p.m. until  Monday 7:00 a.m. I'm just curious like  and I don't think you shouldn't have a  weekend but I think everybody's ambition  actually is more predicated on their  actions than their words my friends tell  me all the time they're so ambitious and  I'm like if that's true then you punt  leisure and you punt concerts at Jones  Beach and you work time so for me my mom  credit golf for me tears down a job for  me unless you know these demons job for  me she's no evil not far from me I don't  mind just a rule